salió de su silencio el fundador de
facebook mark zuckerberg publicó un
largo artículo en su cuenta personal
para defenderse en el centro de estas
acusaciones está la idea de que
priorizamos los beneficios sobre la
seguridad y el bienestar esto no es
cierto el comunicado es la respuesta a
las acusaciones de français haugen
antigua jefa de producto de facebook que
dejó la empresa llevándose consigo miles
de documentos confidenciales
estoy aquí hoy porque creo que los
productos de facebook están perjudicando
a los niños fomentando la división y
debilitando nuestra democracia los
líderes de la compañía saben cómo hacer
que facebook e instagram sean más
seguros pero no harán los cambios
necesarios porque ponen sus astronómicos
beneficios por delante de las personas
como respuesta el fantasma de la
regulación de las redes sociales está
volviendo a washington ayer el senado
escuchó las denuncias de joven y la casa
blanca pidió acciones
esta es sólo la última de una serie de
revelaciones sobre las plataformas de
medios sociales que han dejado claro que
la autorregulación no está funcionando
un sentimiento compartido incluso por
los republicanos en contra de la
compañía valor en un billón de dólares
pero hasta ahora los esfuerzos por
regular mejor las redes sociales han
tenido dificultades para materializarse
mientras se acusa que la plataforma fue
usada para entre otros planear
asesinatos masivos en mianmar o el mismo
asalto el 6 de enero al capitolio por
partidarios del ex presidente de donald
trump